[Music]
straight ahead
on lawn crime daily new details in the
investigation of the doomsday cult
couple
seeing photos of j.j valo in the days
before police say
he was murdered and buried he had duct
tape
continuously wrapped from elbow
all the way around his arms over his
hands roddy rie's defense presents new
evidence they say
clears his name people believe more
finality than they do on justice
the two-week long hearing underway as
his defense argues for a new trial
and opening statements in the murder
case that made america rethink
rideshare safety did nathaniel roland
kill college student samantha josephson
after she allegedly got into his car
thinking he was her uber driver
plus robert durst's defense
cross-examines the lead investigator
who reopened the case into the
disappearance of the millionaire's wife
what we know about kathy durst presumed
murder law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
police release a cachet of documents
with new details
about the doomsday cult couple
investigation long crimes angenette levy
has been sifting through the records
and is here with what she found
brian these new these emails include
more than 2 000 files that reveal
new details about the disappearance and
deaths
of j.j valo and tyler ryan
this photo shows jj vallo sitting on a
couch on september 22nd
2019. investigators found the photo in
lori valo valodebel's icloud account
jj wearing red pj's the last day he was
known to be alive
nearly nine months later jj's body was
found buried in chad daybel's yard in
rexburg idaho
he was in plastic bags wearing those red
pajamas
he had the same style haircut that he
had
in the videos that i had seen and the
photographs i had seen just prior
to my welfare check with him in
september
a detective from rexburg police
testified last year about what jj's body
looked like when it was buried
his hands were folded like this chest
high
he had duct tape continuously wrapped
from elbow all the way around his arms
over his hands days before jj died
photos of him were taken at a park he
was sitting on a ride
there were also photos of jj with his
older step-sister tyler ryan
tyley's remains were found in the same
yard as her brothers
burned and dismembered one of lori
vallo's friends testified about the last
time she saw jj in september 2019
with valo's brother alex cox he
brought jj into the house um
during the middle of the podcast
okay and
and did you see him bring jj into the
house
yes okay how did alex cox bring jj into
the house
he carried him in and he was asleep
alex cox died of natural causes in
december of 2019
his sister and chad dabell eventually
went to hawaii where investigators kept
tabs on them
and we'll have more on that coming up on
our next edition of law and crime daily
brian thanks angeannette joining us
today is former prosecutor melba pearson
and terry
austin anjanette 2500 files is a lot i
do not envy you with that
what else is in the documents you know
there is a lot in those emails a lot of
them
are correspondence between the
investigators in chandler arizona
and the fbi because the fbi of course
was involved in this case
searching for these children and there
are also emails
and screen grabs of text messages things
like that
between j.j valo's grandmother k
woodcock and
investigators so she was incredibly
concerned
trying to find jj and tyler and it's
just heartbreaking to read all of that
absolutely heartbreaking melba could
this information don't be a sign we are
closer to hearing
a cause of death and why do you think
that hasn't been made public yet
so the only logical reason that i can
think of
that would would necessitate
not releasing the cause of death is
because the investigation is ongoing
if they're still talking to witnesses if
they think that
if they were to say well listen this was
the cause of death
that could affect somebody's potential
testimony they're going to hold off on
releasing that for as long as possible
to make sure they get as much evidence
as possible
and to make sure that the evidence they
get the witness testimony is not tainted
in some way
by the extensive media coverage as well
as
aspects of the cause of death we want to
make sure that we're getting information
that only the killer would know
you know as we've seen a lot in
television and of course from watching
law and crime
you know there's certain information
that police will often hold back from
the public
so that when they are able to verify
someone's testimony
they can match it up with the facts that
they know to be true as opposed to
people you know giving false testimony
because they saw something on tv or they
want to help or
you know for any of a number of reasons
yeah yeah makes sense uh
terry what are your thoughts about
melanie gibbs testimony and the last
time she saw jj
yeah you know brian i think that was
very odd that jj
was being carried over alex's shoulder
jj was seven at the time
and it seems a little odd that he was
quote unquote asleep as melanie
testified
she was there doing the podcast in
laurie's house between september 19th
and 23rd
and the last time jj was seen was
on the 22nd reported missing on the 23rd
so
it's a coincidence but it seems to me
that maybe he
might have been even drugged at that
time of course he could have been sleep
but he could have been dead so i don't
know still a lot of questions even after
that 2500
page uh dump of information in this case
we'll continue to follow
the doomsday cult couple case as it
progresses thank you everyone
turning now to other top legal news
convicted rapist harvey weinstein is in
california
facing more sexual assault charges he
could spend the rest of his life in
prison
if found guilty weinstein was extradited
from new york state prison on tuesday
where he is serving a 23-year sentence
for rape
and sexual assault he is facing 11
charges in los angeles
related to five different incidents at
beverly hills hotels
between 2004 and 2013. if convicted
weinstein faces up to 140 years in
prison
new documents reveal how the fbi hired
serial killer
james whitey bulger as an informant
before he fled from boston in the 1970s
it happened when vulgar received a tip
from an fbi agent
that the agency was close to indicting
him 300 pages of information also detail
the agency's investigation into bulgar
including cases of loan sharking
fixing a horse race in pennsylvania and
drug deals around boston in the 70s
he was convicted in 11 murders in 2013
and sentenced to two full-life terms
he was killed inside a west virginia
prison hours after being transferred in
2018.
five members of the disgraced rap artist
security team are indicted for allegedly
chasing down
and robbing a man of his phone one of
the suspects a former nypd detective
is also charged with falsely reporting
the incident manhattan's district
attorney says a five-person team
protecting takashi 6-9
chased down the 34 year old victim when
he took out his phone to film the rapper
in harlem last year
the officer reported multiple times the
victim threatened the five men with a
gun
but investigators found no evidence of
the claim
still ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements in the fake uber
driver murder trial
but first roddy reid gets a new day in
court the evidence his defense says
clears his name and the suspect they're
now pointing fingers at in the murder of
a young woman
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back a special hearing is
underway in the rodney reed case
defense attorneys say they have new
evidence that could prove his innocence
when rodney reed was on trial it was not
fair
the testimony was wrong jared adams is
part of a team of attorneys from the
innocence project
hoping to convince a texas judge that
rodney reed deserves a new trial
if this was about getting it right then
both sides would agree
that we should test everything interview
every witness
to make sure that we got it right for
more than two decades reed sat on death
row
convicted of the 1996 rape and murder of
stacy stites
his execution was stayed by a texas
court of criminal appeals in 2019
his case was remanded back to the
bastrop trial court reid maintains his
innocence and his defense says
many of the state's experts called at
trial have since recanted
on day one of the hearing his defense
called dr andrew baker the chief medical
examiner in hennepin county
who testified at derrick showman's trial
about george floyd's autopsy
baker says he believes steins died much
earlier than the state presented at
trial
a group of renowned forensic
pathologists including dr michael bodden
signed off on an independent study
saying the state's timeline
is medically impossible and she was
lying in such a position that the
lividity
on the front of her chest meant that she
had been face down
the time she was in her residence with
her fiance
for four or five hours but crime scene
investigators say steitz was found face
up
on her back the defense points to her
fiance jimmy fennell a former police
officer
as an alternative suspect he was tried
and convicted
for the same type of offense kidnapping
and raping a woman
on day two of the hearing the defense
called arthur snow a former inmate who
served time with fanel
snow signed a sworn affidavit saying
fennel approached him in 2019
wanting protection from the aryan
brotherhood and confess
that his fiancee had been sleeping
around with a black man behind his back
using a racial slur saying i had to kill
the n-word
loving fiance on cross snow pleaded the
fifth when pressed by the prosecution
about his account the defense plans to
call more inmates who also say finale
confessed to them
and for adams an exoneree turned lawyer
this hearing is about getting to the
truth
and i'll i'll just tell you this when
someone is going through
something like this in prison it is easy
to have yourself filled with doubt but i
could not go on that way i lived each
day like i was getting out the next
and i promised myself if i was
successful i would become a part of this
to help it and that's what i've done by
becoming an attorney
let's bring back former prosecutor melba
pearson and terry austin
mel but with so many witnesses recanting
is there anything the prosecution
can rely on in this hearing the only
thing that the prosecution really has
going for them
is any physical evidence or any
statements that
may have been made at the time of the
offense
but with all of these high profile you
know experts coming out
saying that this is medically impossible
you know there were
other letters that could have spoken to
the consensual nature of the
relationship
that he had with the victim you know all
of these things are not going to weigh
in the prosecution's favor this is not
really looking good for them yeah terry
let's talk about some of those experts
how did dr baker
hold up after being crossed by the
prosecution did his findings that the
timing of stein's death
makes sense you know dr baker held up
extremely well
and i think that his findings were
logical even to a layperson he said he
had
serious qualms about the timing of the
death of the victim as you mentioned
and he explained that the state of the
victim at the time of her death didn't
wasn't consistent with what the
prosecution had said he said that the
length of
time that the sperm is in the body
wasn't consistent he said that
he disputed the bruises on her body
and he also talked about the pulling of
the blood brian so all of these things
really were logical they made sense and
i think that the jury
and a lay person and the judge and
anyone else involved listening to this
type of testimony
will believe and understand that the
timing is just
off it just wasn't right it's all about
timing here the prosecution's case
rested a lot on that
as this hearing continues we'll make
sure to bring you updates to see whether
or not rodney reed
gets a new trial or is vindicated by
this information thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily the
jury seated in the case of a man accused
of posing as a rideshare driver before
killing a college student
plus robert durst on trial where fact
meets fiction the hollywood movies
played for the jury and the real life
investigators taking the stand
ahead
[Music]
welcome back jurors in the robert durst
trial are watching the movie
all good things which is loosely based
off the defendant's life
this comes after we learn the movie's
directors will not be testifying
robert dress is accused of killing his
best friend susan berman in december
2000
prosecutors say he plotted to kill
berman after she threatened she'd go
public with information
about the 1982 disappearance of his
first wife kathy
new york state police investigator
joseph becerra reopened kathy's case in
1999
and says he was planning to speak with
berman when he learned she was killed
but durst defense maintains there's no
evidence linking durst to either death
but at no time did you find any physical
evidence showing
that mr durst had talked to susan berman
to plot any kind of strategy for mr
durst as far as an alibi did you
that is correct do you know where
the rumor or the theory that susan
berman
had called the school began objection is
also calling for hearsay also outside
the scope
it's a state were you in meetings
with the lada
where the lada or the lapd suggested
that miss berman had called the law uh
medical school
calling for hearsay to stay
back to discuss the newest chapter in
the dirt saga is former prosecutor melba
pearson
and co-host terry austin melville the
prosecution wanted becerra to show
durst may have known the investigation
was reopened
but after the cross was it worth it
well you know this is definitely a mixed
bag type situation
uh definitely this is a technique to
plant the seed
in the jury's mind that maybe this could
be the motive
now granted they don't have any evidence
to back it up and hopefully
uh in the jury looking at the case as a
whole
will still be able to come to that
conclusion from the prosecution's
perspective
but again it's a gamble because if
they're putting out something where
there's not a whole lot of evidence to
back it up
then you know you end up losing
credibility and you lose points with the
jury so
we'll have to wait and see how this move
panned out but this was to plant the
seed in the jury's mind with regards to
the motive
yeah let's see how that seed fares if
lewin waters it with his words he'll
definitely grow
terry it seemed like the defense was
stopped at every turn by judge windham
uh what about what do you think about
his rulings during the cross
you know there's no question that judge
windham is leaning
backwards for lewin and the prosecution
team there's
no question about that when on
cross-examination
the defense asks sarah listen where did
this rumor begin
about susan berman calling the dean
pretending to be
kathy we get an objection from lewin
that is the crux of the prosecution's
case that's what they've been talking
about and trying to establish
that was theoretically part of the
motive behind
killing susan berman and yet the judge
sustained the objection by lewin and
said that it wasn't relevant it is
relevant so i think
all in all the defense is trying very
hard to put their case in
and just moving on when they are ruled
against because they don't want to look
like the judge is ruling against them
the entire time
yeah we'll see how this all ties in
together of course uh prosecutor lewin
is phenomenal in terms of his knowledge
of the law i would not put it passing
that these are proper objections but
just
from the outside in it seems like he's
having his way with this case and the
defense is just being stopped at every
juncture
thank you both when we come back a young
woman murdered after getting into the
wrong
car thinking it was her uber ride the
man accused of killing her
now on trial opening statements after
the break
welcome back a south carolina man is now
on trial for the murder of a college
student who allegedly got into his car
thinking it was her uber driver 27 year
old nathaniel rowland is charged with
kidnapping and murdering
21-year-old samantha josephson in march
2019.
she was last seen on surveillance video
around 2am getting into the back seat of
a car
she thought was her uber according to
investigators the victim's blood and
cell phone were found inside roland's
car
and prosecutors say he was fixated on
her circling around the block
until she got in
cameras record nathaniel roland's 2017
black impala as it pulls into a parking
space
next to where samantha is waiting
by herself for that uber and she
mistakenly
gets into that vehicle owned by
the defendant nathaniel david rowland
and we know that to be true because
those cameras and five points that i
mentioned to you
captured those things the evidence will
show
that after she got into that vehicle
that's the last time
that anybody saw her alive the next time
that somebody saw
samantha josephson she was found alone
in the woods covered in her own blood
dead she'd been stabbed
multiple times from the bottom of her
feet
throughout her torso throughout her face
her neck and her head
defense attorneys say the victim is not
to blame for her murder
nor is their client they claim someone
else was driving his car
at the time zero
that's the amount of dna
on samantha josephson's body that
matches nathaniel roland
zero it's not on her clothing
it's not under her ripped and torn
fingernails
it's not on her ankles nathaniel's dna
is not there but someone else's
is multiple someones
remember those swabs that the crime
scene agents took from his car
from the steering wheel from the gear
shift
from the door handles
more dna that does not belong
to nathaniel roland
melville the prosecution made a strong
point in saying that roland's cell phone
was tracked when samantha's during this
entire time
how strong of an opening was this i
thought it was a pretty solid opening
you know because he really
painted a very visual picture with
regards to
the amount of trauma that she went
through before she died that she was
stabbed from
the bottom of her feet all the way up to
the top of her head so it definitely
centers the jury on what happened to her
and then
also then causes them to ask the
question well then why
is your cell phone tracking with you
know miss joseph sins
if you weren't involved with her in any
way shape or form if you
somebody else was driving your car you
weren't at the scene then there's no
logical reason
for the two cell phones to be together
so i think that they really
set a high bar with this opening
statement and we'll definitely see how
the evidence
pans out because remember an opening
statement is not evident so
we're going to have to see what the
actual evidence ends up being
and how they're going to be able to
rebut the points that the defense
brought up in their opening
yeah i thought the prosecution opening
reminded me of an olympian it was lean
strong and executed almost perfectly
terry the defense's opening
uh called samantha a fighter and painted
and pointed sorry
to the fact that none of her dna none of
roland's dna was on her in any way shape
or form not even under
her broken fingernails what did you
think of the opening
well i thought it was lean and strong
and executed perfectly i thought the
defense did a great job
here i didn't like the fact that she
started by quoting numbers because i've
heard that before
and it's a little you know mundane but
she did say
something about not saying anything bad
about samantha that was good and the
no dna and the no cuts on the body was
good
absolutely thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you